a lot of it is really fun even a lot of
I had an editor on when I worked on the
Metro desk at the new york times he
would send you to these stories that
were just funny and he'd go well it's
just it's just weird and that's how I
felt a lot you know there's so many
things about the Brits that are just
weird and I have a chapter about the
British British men and sex and sex in
general and the euphemisms they use I
mean I am you know they won't say vagina
they say front bottom if a man in an
older man goes to the hospital and he's
having trouble urinating he'll say I
have a problem with my water works as if
they were utility and monopoly you know
like the electric company and I started
compiling experiences that men would
tell me about how they learned about sex
in school and I think you know now they
have a curriculum that you're actually
supposed to teach sex ed in my kids
school there was a huge fight over how
explicit you know they were going to
make the sex ad because a lot of these
English people didn't want their kids to
know these words but so these men you
know like my age or maybe a little bit
older would say talk about what happened
and one of them said for example they
the teacher said so okay so we're going
to learn about sex and I got all excited
and the guy put a video you know they
watched a video of two racehorses
fucking in a field basically and that
was it they didn't talk about it they
didn't apply it to humans they didn't
discuss you know contraception that was
all they watched and he was like and he
said it took him years to realize that
you didn't have to do it from ba and
then another guy I said you know the guy
said we're going to discuss sex and they
showed him a bunch of slides of dizzy
diseased penises you know this is like
don't do it because this is what's going
to happen to you um so it's very very
weird and and you know so there's a lot
of stuff like that and I tried to kind
of think of funny stuff and each thing
that I wrote about I wrote about the
house of lords and their
had a huge kind of battle over ejecting
the hereditary legislators who were
there because they their parents had
been in the House of Lords you know they
inherited their seed and legislators
like senators inheriting the ability to
be a senator I was ridiculous but they
had this amazing debate over whether
they should actually kick them out or
not and it was just it was like some
baroque you know play it was like
Gilbert and Sullivan listening to these
people and but yet it was Lapointe you
know they were getting up and saying my
family's been here since 1500 and maybe
were not you know elected politicians
but but we feel a kind of duty to the
country and we feel that we're able to
take a step back and not have to worry
about the electorate so we look after it
is a kind of caretakers and then they
all got kicked out and 90 of them were
allowed to stay in their seats but they
had to run to stay in their seats that
they had an election which they never
had before and it was so funny because
they were trying to campaign yet it's
uncool for them to campaign they didn't
want to be seen as boasting or saying
that we're really great so they tried to
do these like little mission statements
and there were so funny and one of them
said you know my credentials are that
I'm a bison farmer another said I know
how to operate heavy machinery and
another said I had experience because I
worked as the private secretary to
Princess Margaret and my job is up so
I'll have some time if you know I have
time free to work here if you want me
but they just couldn't do like a normal
job or they'd say you know I myself
don't want to run but some few of my
kind friends feel that perhaps I could
you know contribute something very sweet
you